israeli air strikes on gaza that
continued from friday across the weekend
killing more than a dozen including a
commander of islamic jihad
and a five-year-old girl israel had
struck without being attacked first its
prime minister said it was to remove a
threat hanging over the country from
islamic jihad following israel's
detention of its leader in the occupied
west bank on monday
israel carried out a precise
counter-terror operation against an
immediate threat
our fight is not with the people of gaza
islamic jihad is an iranian proxy that
wants to destroy the state of israel and
kill innocent israelis
israel authorized the use of reservists
and mobilized combat battalions and
artillery units meanwhile islamic jihad
hit back launching barrages of rockets
we just seen rockets streaming overhead
coming from gaza into israel and there's
been scores and scores of them since the
start of this but they haven't really
had
much impact a lot of them have been
stopped by the iron dome which is
israel's anti-rocket system a lot of
them have landed within gaza or have
gone into unpopulated
areas so it's a real sign of the
unevenness of this struggle really
between the israeli strikes and what
islamic jihad is able to use to hit back
israeli towns around gaza were still on
red alert and people were warned not to
gather in large numbers
nogagust lives in kibbutz methalseem in
a house the bomb shelter acquired by
israeli law a sign of how entrenched and
cyclical this conflict has become so
this is
the entrance to my to the
safe room
nogal wants peace but also supported
israel striking first i loved it
first time since
ever
that israel is taking the initiative
israel is the one that
actually saying what will happen
and not the hamas or the jihad
israel's leaders too say that they're
taking control but they also know it's
election season
many analysts have said that this is all
about the acting prime minister and
defense minister showing their tough
insecurity in a country where that wins
votes others aren't so sure
this is the first time that i've seen
preemptive strike in many years
and when you try to connect that the
decision to do a preemptive strike to
election
maybe there is a linkage there we
definitely don't know that for sure
it's you know basically we live through
threats security threats all the time
and then apparently we live through
election cycles all the time so the
linkage is not that clear to me
now everyone's waiting to see if this
escalates that could depend on if hamas
the real ruling power in gaza joins this
fight john holman al jazeera ashkelon